derzeit gelten strenge ausgangs
verschränkungen 3
alles leer keiner da es sind
einschränkungen wie es sie in der
bundesrepublik noch nie
das ist im grunde genommen wie so ein
ganz großes experiment was jetzt
passiert wenn dieses sozialkontakte von
außen so stark eingeschränkt werden
das gibt ihr ein gesicht das klopapier
wegnehmen und es gibt die anderen die
selbst das letzte abend jetzt teil
ich hoffe sehr dass die maßnahmen
ausreichen dass man denn in deutschland
echte schnell gelobt jetzt gehandelt hat
vor nicht mal einem monat hat noch
keiner drüber nachgedacht dass es jemals
so weit kommen würde wie es jetzt gerade
ist und jetzt sind wir aber gut in der
situation und das ist einfach ein
krasser einschnitt in das leben was wir
normalerweise führen deswegen wollen wir
uns heute mal angucken was das
eigentlich für auswirkungen haben kann
auf uns und auf unsere psyche
wie ihr seht hier ist alles ziemlich
leer und ausgestorben
und das ist auch gut so denn wir sollten
uns alle ja mit so wenig menschen wie
möglich treffen und auf welche leute ist
besonders zu betrifft sind die menschen
in quarantäne und einer davon werde ich
gleich ein paar einkäufe vorbeibringen
anna hat bis vor kurzem in einem
krankenhaus im risikogebiet in
norditalien gearbeitet
sie wollte eigentlich ihren job machen
und wurde jetzt aber nach hause
geschickt denn das krankenhaus konnte
nicht mehr für ihre sicherheit
garantieren so ich bin jetzt fester und
für so einen ganz normalen wochentag
nachmittag ist es hier wirklich fast
gespenstisch ruhig ich werde jetzt
gleich klingeln und dann die sachen
bei anna vor die tür stellen
beziehungsweise die fenster sind sogar
offen da und ich hoffe wir einfach mal
obwohl wir jetzt also in der selben
stadt sind sprechen wir aus
sicherheitsgründen die wasg ein
so hat es diverse probleme in italien
und deutschland was dann wieder ganz
anderes ja genau so wirklich zwei
unterschiedliche welten also dass fast
keine züge mehr
und wenn man da ganz alleine auf der
straße ist das ist mehr als gespenstisch
und so real also das waren wirklich sehr
emotional muss ich sagen da alleine zu
sein und dann wird man überall gefragt
wo man hingehen möchte und man geht aus
der haustür raus und das vergleich die
polizei an einem vorbei
wir waren so glaube ich 50 leute am
flughafen alles geschlossen möglich war
einfach keiner da und dann war
polizeikontrolle und ich nur zwei drei
mal gefragt wieso ich überhaupt raus
möchte wieso ich reise nun in
deutschland ja wenn ich dann einfach
raus und hab meinen koffer genommen und
aus und wird nicht einmal gefragt mit
herkommen was ich mache oder wo ich
jetzt hin gierig wird nicht auf
hingewiesen dass es diese freiwillige
quarantäne gibt dass ich aus einem
risikogebiet kommen wird sich das für
dich an gefühlt gerade wenn du erzählt
sie dass in italien war dieser
unterschied italien deutschland hat mich
schon sehr schockiert ehrlich ich wollte
in italien ganz häufig angespannt ist
die situation in deutschland wieso nimmt
man das denn nicht ernst denkt denn
wirklich jeder dass wir einen fehler
gemacht haben oder wir nicht in der lage
werden
auch zuschauen oder dass ihr so viel es
zeit das hat man so in italien
aufgenommen
dieses diese hört ihr denn nicht unsere
unsere warnung das ist nicht was was nur
in italien ist es ist nicht nur ein
problem für ein land wie die war so ein
gefühl wie ist das gefühl wie geht es
den leuten in italien was hast du da so
erlebt weil man hofft es die maßnahmen
greifen bald und deshalb hat man ein
ziel vor augen und man gestaltet das
zusammen und das ist das glaube ich was
das land und die menschen dort momentan
trägt da zieht wirklich jeder an einem
strang ich hab das dort zb nicht erlebt
das toilettenpapier ausverkauft ist
und das war ja hier schon von zwei
wochen obwohl hier alles normal
weiterging von italien wurden alles
runter gefahren und da gab's noch alle
manche menschen fürchten italien sei
deutschland noch einige tage voraus dass
das land so heftig vom virus überrollt
wurde hat viele überrascht
auch da ist die frage wieso das jetzt
gerade so exportiert also an zahlen und
an das ist ja und ernst sind ja nicht
nur zwei ja ganz viele menschen dahinter
ganz viele
ja das ist das was mir sehr viel angst
macht unterschätzt dass wir es nicht das
ist die botschaft die sie schon vor ein
paar wochen aus italien an ihre freundin
in deutschland oder auf der ganzen welt
verschickt hat nehmt es ernst und bleibt
zu hause
dass das geht hat sie zwei wochen lang
erlebt was ich sagen kann ist dass oder
aus italien man auf jeden fall wege
findet auch zu hause gemeinsam ob sie
bei sky bist oder telefon oder
vielleicht auch einfach mal alleine für
sich zu sein und meine ruhe zu finden
und dass es auf jeden fall möglich ist
auf vieles zu verzichten wenn man
dadurch überspitzt dargestellt aber
leben retten kann
anders tipp zum überstehen der
quarantäne oder der ausgangssperre
ich glaube was ganz wichtig ist dass man
sich nicht immer die ganze zeit sagt
dass man nicht mehr raus da und das dass
das ist man das alles nicht davon dass
man jetzt in trin gefangen ist desto
weil ich habe das gefühl je mehr ich mir
das präsent werden lassen in welcher
situation ich bin desto schlimmer wird
ist zwar beeindruckend das gespräch mit
anna und das zeigt auch dass trotz allem
und trotzdem situation wie schlimm das
da gerade vorrat ist ja auch zuversicht
herrschen kann trotzdem sind wir eine
situation in der so viel unsicherheit
herrscht und weil er so viele fragen
offen bleiben und dass wir alle darauf
achten müssen dass uns damit geht auch
einfach auf uns hören müssen was macht
es denn mit uns kann man das aus
psychologischer sicht irgendwie
einschätzen oder sagen ich denke es gibt
ja jetzt so beide seiten diejenigen die
jetzt gerade niemanden haben
sehr schnell einsam werden das sind eben
freundin alleinstehende oder
alleinlebende person und diejenigen die
einer familie und sicherung haben und
jetzt also eine art lagerkoller bekommen
die würden sich wahrscheinlich mehr
freiräume einfach wünschen und mehr
möglichkeiten sich auch mal zurückziehen
zu können
das sind die zwei extreme susanne becker
ist psychologin und wissenschaftlerin
und aktuell wie sie mit einer studie
erforschen wie sich unser leben durch
die korona krise verändert man darf das
was gar nicht so sagen das ist auch im
gespannt ist weil natürlich irgendwie
für die allermeisten menschen eine so
schwierige situationen ist aber
natürlich ist es das forschungs sich
sehr sehr spannend wenn auf einmal
sozialen kontakte von außen so stark
reglementiert werden und damit etwas
passiert was uns als mensch und wir sind
eben nun mal soziale wesen eigentlich
total zuwiderläuft was sind zu
strategien wie kann man jetzt mit so
einer situation umgehen wenn man
niemanden um sich hat und beschützen
würde ich auf jeden fall empfehlen die
kontaktmöglichkeiten die man hat so weit
es geht auszuschöpfen auch wenn wir uns
physisch distanzieren dass wir uns eben
psychologisch nicht so weit distanziert
sich so und ihnen aufrecht zu erhalten
die man auch sonst im alltag hatte damit
man eben gar nicht erst ja in so einem
sumpf des alleine und einsam science
hineingerät ich denke das sind alles
deutlich sinnvollere und funktionale
strategien als jetzt nur serien zu
schauen oder so etwas auf der anderen
seite halte ich aber eben auch für
wichtig dass man gut kommuniziert wie es
ein netz gerade geht und auch dass man
sagt dass man sich jetzt irgendwie alle
einsam oder alleine gelassen fühlt das
ist erfahrungsgemäß ziemlich schwierig
also über einsamkeit zu sprechen war
zumindest vor corona etwas was sehr
stark stigmatisiert war und ich hoffe
einfach dass diese situation jetzt auch
dazu beiträgt dass es vielleicht
leichter wird über dieses gefühl zu
sprechen weil mehr menschen das
nachvollziehen können und es nicht mehr
ganz so fremd erscheint dieser faktor
dass keiner weiß wie lange das noch
dauert werden ja das ist schwierig das
ist total spieler richtig glaube auch
dass das viel stress und angst er 2 das
führt dann möglicherweise auch zu all
diesen überzogenen hamsterkäufen weil
man sich ebenso große sorgen ja aber
wenn das jetzt dann auch so und so lange
und dann reicht manchen papier doch
nicht mehr
das ist halt ja das ist wirklich ein
bisschen schwierig ich würde mir
eigentlich auch wünschen dass es klarer
kommuniziert wird wie lange solche
zustände jetzt gelten
wir haben selbst wenn er nicht einsam
sein ist das hier wirklich gerade eine
zeit die eine große herausforderung für
uns alle ist deswegen diese fünf tipps
was ihr tun könnt um besser durch die
korona zeit zu kommen
erstens nutzt nicht zu viele medien und
lesen nicht zu viele krone nachrichten
berichtet euch am besten irgendwann am
tag eine uhrzeit ein um euch sachen
anzugucken und danach passte
zweitens geht euren tagesstruktur dann
steht man auf wann ist man beim macht
man sport wann trifft man sich mit
freunden was wochentag war das
wochenende dritter hört euch rein und
lasst eure gefühle zu und das geht
direkt über in vier spricht mit leuten
darüber wie es euch geht und der fünfte
punkt linke zu verbannen
essen trinken und sich bewegen nicht
vergessen
und trotzdem für den fall dass die merkt
dass es euch nicht gut geht seht ihr
jetzt hier diverse nummern die er
anrufen könnt wenn es euch nicht gut
geht wir packen es euch auch unten in
die infobox und traut euch bitte
nachzufragen einer telefonnummer und ein
chat unter dem ihr anonym
24 stunden am tag 7 tage die woche
jemanden erreichen können ist die
telefonseelsorge 100 wie erlebt ihr denn
so die letzten tage hat sich die arbeit
bei euch irgendwie schon verändert total
also wir haben gerade aktuell mal
gezählt die zahlen muss um den virus
gegen den umgang mit der pandemie das
ist erschreckend wie nach oben
geschnellt sind aber dass das schöne
auch die dies bereite der kolleginnen
und kollegen ist größer vollen dienstag
wir sind wirklich da tag und nacht unten
liegen
mir geht es nicht gut ich rufe bei der
telefonseelsorge an was passiert dann
sie werden erstmal mit einer warmen
stimme empfangen und sie haben einen
ehrenamtlichen oder eine ehrenamtliche
am telefon
menschen mit jedes erfahrung menschen
mit einer richtig guten soliden
ausbildung viele sind anderthalb jahre
auf dem weg zu dieser arbeiten lassen
sich ausbilden und dann wirklich ganz
von ganzem herzen für die leute da zu
sagen in welchen fällen kann ich mich
dann an die telefonseelsorge wenden wenn
das gefühl ist nicht muss jetzt mit
jemandem sprechen ich brauche jetzt
etwas ich brauche jetzt eine wahl stehen
ein offenes hören
dann rufen sie an es ist okay alles ist
erlaubt hier kann jeder und jede mit
ihren themen kommen
endlich
[Musik]